every cell in your body has six billion
base pairs I carry how much fewer and
each of those DNA base pairs a C's DS of
T's gets converted to RNA and protein
and each of those folds up and the
protein s 20 amino acids and triplets
and so along the way we said oh we not
only have to so in crystallography was
the first fields it was automated and I
said let's automate everything else so
we I mean that wasn't my main thing but
that was something was relatively easy
to do from my experience up to that
point we did DNA and then proteins and
then RNA and then systems biology where
you figure out what it all does in
principle and in synthetic biology where
you test your notions of what it all
does and that's kind of the phase were
in right now almost everything we do is
about reading and writing complex
biological systems ranging from the
atomic level the organs organisms and
even ecosystems and you can just you can
use the general basis of one of these
very versatile tools that you can use at
all kinds of scales